[Music]
all right so this this whole thing's
been going on this this is a whole thing
that happened with God for those who
don't know the Eric July
thing um what I think I have the ice
don't show it on screen it'll copyright
strike us all right well instead I'll
show a better book what are the odds
Mike Lindell there you go from crackhead
to crackhead again
crackhead to crack poot look look let's
pretend that this copy of rhinestone
with Dolly Parton Sylvester alone is an
isome comic Let's Pretend that's what
we're looking at why do you I can't
because that's a far better piece of
media oh because I couldn't find it on
Blu-ray um
so anyway um um what if our fans sent it
I mean obvious it's just weird like just
a weird choice and something to
send um so
anyway uh ra so Eric jalai was upset
because Riley went pulled up as it were
to his place of business specifically
asked to pull up and he did pull up and
he put stickers with dollar sign with
like re IRL super chats which was very
funny which was funny and then I loved I
loved how intense he was ignore these
super chats you son of a [__]
this and then Rada is going after him
and then after this dick Masterson goes
on Rada show and almost [__] say
legally reactional things that he
probably shouldn't be saying which is
very funny um but anyway Eric Rada was
talking about which the one thing about
Rada that I I do like is that he's very
like look if you want to ask me about
the law I will tell you the answer as a
lawyer this is the law he'll tell you
his opinions aside like legally what's
going on right so of course since it
wasn't them saying that that that Isam
was the best comic that was ever written
Eric jly was literally in ricor chat
being like let me hop on let me hop on I
want to talk to you let me hop on so he
did and here's what happened fine I
don't need to here is uh Eric I'm
bringing you in you're you already give
me a thumbs up all right hey man what's
shaking what's up what's up man what's
up too much drama man too much drama and
I think uh there's a lot of
misunderstanding going on but um look
let's just uh let's just be out with it
be fully Frank I'm good with that I
wanna I want to bury all this [__]
because I I hate this stuff so okay uh
what you got for me man oh no I figured
that instead of like you know talking
around it and you know at talking at
audience and all that good stuff I
figure that why not talk directly
definitely if uh you know I'm saying
something about you or you saying
something about me I figured why not
talk talk directly I've been with you
kind of sounds like what Riley figured
he was doing yeah yeah and then and then
then you [__] got his [__] Twitter
taken down I think this whole kind of
ordeal is gay um it should be ended uh
however yeah yeah yeah yeah but you went
after like false flag like you well your
people let me not say you yeah you
you've and I don't mean black people I
mean like your is on people you have
been escalating it every single step of
the way I think in order for that you
said pull up had to kind of be on the
table if that's something that we all
started because a libertarian said pull
up and a guy did to his public [__]
warehouse and they were libertarian an
anarcho capitalist who who didn't
believe in intellectual property rights
until he had intellectual property and
then and then dmca his [__] clip ofe
thing that he made too which is by the
way completely parody which is why now
he's in a trademark battle because then
people found the International School of
ministry which holds the trademark to
Isam and then they were like all right
so people snitched him out to this
[__] International School of
ministers and now you're getting sued
over real trademark [__] it's like every
time you do something to harm somebody
it comes back tenfold on you and you
just aren't
learning this initially we need to be
honest about it and let's not act like
this is one of those hey this is this
guy versus that guy thing that's not
what this is I didn't start this um
nothing to do had nothing to do with any
of that um but yeah it's reached kind of
a level that is you know it's gay I I
agree with that 100 per. yeah and to be
very clear I don't know if you heard or
saw or maybe you did you didn't think it
was genuine and I don't know but I did
say that um you know Riley going to your
place of business while I don't think it
was illegal and we may have some
disagreements over that and there may be
details that I can't see uh in regards
to the property but from what I've seen
I don't think it's illegal but I did say
bad move he shouldn't do it given the
tension I think it's a really really bad
play um I don't like
it to me either I get it uh so that was
that was a thing I said last night when
it was brought up to me I wasn't aware
of it until someone super chated and I
had to like look in I might have seen it
or something but uh someone super
chatted and I addressed it right then um
in my last stream so I do not think he
should have gone to your place of
business at all uh but at the same time
like if people ask me about legalities
specifically self-defense like I'm going
to give him my legal opinion that's uh
that's still true and I was I think
right before um uh we got or that I saw
that you were in chat I was saying that
there are two practicalities right
there's what you can legally do and then
there's what you should and shouldn't do
I think what Riley did is something you
shouldn't do so uh I want to be very
clear on that and and I'm cool with that
uh I you know there is a point of
contention there um there I'm obviously
not a lawyer but I'm at least familiar
you're an idiot see I would have fell
for it too was too
loud that that was the problem is it was
it was too
loud almost had me
though hold on let me try this again
hold on this probably like this let's
justar enough with it that would with
our team as well as what's actually
happening on it um you know again my
issue with it is less legal uh versus
illegal anyway but again I do question
that whole legality aspect of it all
because is you're a [__] he sounds
like a buffoon like he talks like a
buffoon and and and and it's weird
because what when when he was doing his
comic stuff you know it's fine but it's
like money sometimes does this to people
where it makes them think that because
they've made a large sum of money that
they are smarter like that that like
that makes them like some sort of weird
intellectual yeah no that's that's
pretty much everybody
especially when you're a [__]
YouTuber which is basically what like I
I get it he thinks he's a big comic book
writer but really you're a YouTuber you
were a comic culture commentator that's
all you do you know none of us are
smart I make the argument and certainly
everybody here is making the argument
that for sure definitely considering at
night time that yeah Forest goes that's
all grifting Libertarians nobody hates
Libertarians more than other
Libertarians and Libertarians want to
win but every time a Libertarian
succeeds the other Libertarians gets
call not a real libertarian and then
they all fight with each other yeah and
then they kick everybody out of the Free
State movement is criminal mischief
right uh it's not criminal mief look
where kid is like um and definitely
because he's writing on stuff and he's
putting notes up and all oh man he's
putting notes and writing stuff oh snap
stuff and in Texas if you don't know you
can by the way and this is what not
anything that I'm advocating right I
want to be very very clear about that
but you know definitely because we're
talking about the legality of deadly
force and all that good stuff in Texas
oh
yeah deadly for regards to a man putting
stickers on your
window have the right it's right there
in section n of the not a in a business
park yeah I don't know if that's the
same putting stickers on something in a
business park means you could shoot
somebody yeah that's that doesn't If he
if he would have broken into your place
and you would have been in there you
probably could have probably shot him in
Texas I broke this down a little bit on
nightwave but yeah when you have you
have a shared area like an industrial or
a commercial park you don't have a right
to restrict access to the industrial
park to like you don't own any of that
property you're renting the way I said
it on nightwave is you basically have
the what is basically an apartment for
businesses that's what it is so it's it
has apartment type rules it's like if
you live in an apartment building I
can't obstruct the walkway up to my
floor if there's another apartment like
you're not allowed that's not your it's
a common area you have an apartment for
businesses so if like a [__] local
Chinese place was opening up was going
around and putting stickers with their
menus on them you think you could just
shoot the the the Chinese person I
literally made did you okay the same
joke last week I said I'm going to shoot
every [__] that slides a menu under
my door you can't do that can't I'm
pretty sure that's not how it work I'm
not a lawyer or anything even if I have
a sign that says don't put things on my
door no soliciting I still can't just
open fire on
somebody a Texas Penal code and you know
you can read it verbatim but I thought
you didn't care about legal versus
non-legal you said that you the one that
said it is you being able to use deadly
force uh for someone uh committing
criminal mischief at night on on your
properties so but however you know that
aside because that was never really on
the one to I don't know these I want to
get to a certain part I don't know if
you got to the part where he was talking
about is there a gate like to your thing
like to the warehouse and all that yeah
he starts breaking he started sounding
really dumb there something like it was
well within the night was completely
down yeah it's like pretty well the
video is well lit I don't know where the
light's coming from no not when he not
when he stuck that I mean maybe it was
well lit in terms of the light but he
was it was maybe it was wellit maybe it
was in terms of light there was a lot of
light this is the stuff I was talking
about but it wasn't that like well lit
but yeah there was a lot of light and it
was well lit though this is the stuff
I'm talking about this is the stuff I'm
talking about this is like pre-
Neanderthal levels of intelligence this
this is the stuff I'm talking about I
was watching this right Eric July is the
kind of guy that wonders where the sun
goes at night I don't yeah like does he
son does sun go to sleep I don't
understand this like wait a second here
you're say it was well lit no no but I'm
not talking about like yeah there was
lights and stuff like what are you
talking about Eric he's filamina cun in
real life yes it's exactly what he is
yes the same brand of Comedy but he's
dead ass serious at night when he did
there was no he didn't the only thing
that he did was kind of weird he kind of
drove in and he backed up and he drove
past it at during the day and took a
picture uh but other than that that was
it he never he never did uh anything
like that during the day that was that
was at night there was nobody there sure
and I again I don't know so I'm I'm
taking your word at it full faith like I
I have no problem accepting that it was
at night I just I wanted to clarify from
someone who knew because like I said
from the video uh it's it's never clear
how lighting [__] plays out so with that
said though um the funny part about law
is like uh there are disagreements over
stuff that many people find obvious and
I got to take one issue with you just on
the the criminal mischief which is what
Texas calls vandalism um criminal
mischief almost always requires some
level of damage or burden on someone so
I think you're running a real risk with
suggesting that stickers on a window is
going to come out to be crial according
to the penal code though he's the lawyer
according to the law though the the
penal code I know a lot about the law
he's the lawyer you're a paint by
numbers comic book writer calm down yeah
yeah but Nick what you don't understand
as I'm a free inhabitant this is the
yeah no I get it nap man oh it
specifically says Mark I think Nick R's
disrespecting you you should beat him up
yeah why don't you pull up food
inscriptions slogans drawns that's all
so you [__] idiot yes I know but he's
a [__] you have to remember something
that what's what's been
Expo this is there's a there's another
Universe if you believe in like the
Multiverse Theory right where the
everything went the same way but he just
went like I guess like my comic's not
for everyone that's okay man you don't
have to read it all right have thanks
though M and that's all he had to say
right and then he'd still be making his
millions of dollars and he wouldn't have
to be getting trademark sued or any of
this stuff but instead he had to [__]
do it he had to play the [__] tough
guy and what all that happened is is
everything is unraveling now because of
it people would have respected him more
maybe not thinking he's the smartest guy
in the world obviously but people would
have been like you know what though
self-made man he said he was going to
[__] he said of talking [__] about other
Comics he went out and made it look it's
not for me but good on him all he had to
do was be like no but instead you
[__] started the [__] storm with
people to have Rada do a six-hour
response [__] video I I get what
you're saying but you're setting a
pretty high Bar for a guy who I now I've
never read isan but somebody told me
that Isam starts off with the phrase two
weeks
ago look I H I have read Isam and I
could tell you that yes so instead of
starting at a certain time and then
saying oh by the way two weeks ago we
just go two weeks ago where is my Isam
copy I definitely have a copy of Isam
that someone sent us like an actual one
that way they don't hit me for copyright
stuff yeah that's how that's how he made
sure isan was timeless it always takes
place two weeks ago mhm that when I
heard that I [__] was howling I'm
like does it really start with two weeks
ago and like but we're not even in now
yet the guy who's powered by sons his
name is Solara cuz son yeah I yeah to
Toyota made it I think for a while right
yes toy cousin Joe had one he did he did
he did you're talking about damage yes
that's included if you can break the wi
and do all that good stuff obviously
that that is completely obvious and you
know I'm willing to this is really
unbelievable to me I mean seriously
except a disagreement but certainly our
guys on that side don't see it that way
and to be honest you know that's I I
think that's what matters however no
what matters is the legality of it
because you're talking to a
lawyer also here's the thing if if you
do think he broke the law you don't go
to a lawyer that's not how any of this
works go to the cops yeah you go to the
police and they and they arrest the guy
and then you can get lawyers involved if
you want to do some civil [__] later but
he keeps doing this well my lawyers tend
to disagree and my lawyers also be
deputies uh so they're gonna come and
arrest him though like no it's not what
matters though because what matters is
what a prosecutor sees rightly there it
is then he goes exactly but you just
said the opposite of that that's my
point about the
buffoonery you know and that's the word
I hear I hear a buffoon you know the law
has played out and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna offer a mild rebuttal and simply
say that inscriptions markings and stuff
like that is referring to Graffiti to
marker to something that's actually
applied to the property that would take
some sort of effort to remove and if you
read a little farther into the statute
you'll actually see them explain that
there has to be some sort of pecuniary
loss or economic burden in either uh the
damage to the property or the removal
from the property and mere incidental um
Anno yeah but we ain't got no pecuniary
outside we got we got nandas yeah does
that matter matter what kind of we have
dandel Lions out there and like some
kind of blue flower thing is removing
something like lavender sticker doesn't
usually measure up now of course there
are some stickers right that a huge
sticker that you slap on you got to get
hire someone to like use solvents and
[__] to remove it these look like
relatively small stickers that would pop
off without any effort I think you'd be
on real Shaky Ground not you sorry you
weren't there but anyone would be on
real Shaky Ground trying to just ify
putting a hole in someone over those
stickers or even suggesting that a
prosecut would uh or a cop even would
write an infraction ticket on this
misdemeanor offense like there's no way
man it's not spray paint uh well again I
I again it's not necessarily we see it
that way definitely considering that you
know there were drawings it doesn't
matter how you see were actually there
and there some weird stuff that now he's
trying to really stra with some weird
stuff some
drawings some things that might be Con
on it and you know I'm not going to sit
up
uh wrote on it I'm not going to sit here
and repeat it uh by any means but you
know I by any means this is like when a
uh Damon Waynes played that prison
character who would just like started
reading books in jail and he's using
words all wrong yeah this is every black
guy in court yeah they just they just
start using what they think is Court
words
dude every black guy who learns the word
behoove
yeah it will behoove you
it's they love the word circumstances
too in in in court they love that one he
uh here this is what I was talking
about before we vote on your request for
parole we do have some questions do you
think you'll be able to adjust to life
on the outside
this yes this is great allow me to pize
myself supposit speaking my
incarceration has forced you say the
ventilation of shall I say my Dairy air
and upon my discharge I will evacuate
excuse me
ejacuate my mind to the like that like
like like by any like you're just adding
words to sound smarter yeah it's black
people Court talk or like a black person
on the
phone that you know that being your sort
of position and that it's always been
the case or you feel like that that's
generally the case of to justify putting
a uh putting a hole or attempting to put
a hole in in someone our guys don't see
it that way and um I've I've seen people
get AED out for a lot less however I
don't even think yeah and then they went
to prison yeah he's literally making the
argument that he could have shot Riley
for putting stickers on his door yeah
Eric we're not all black people it out
for a lot less however I don't even
think I would highly suggest an
alternative opinion on Council if you
think a sticker with a $20 bill under it
justifies if if that's I'll take the
money the argument though that's where I
think the gas liting is that's not the
that's not the POS gaslighting so now
we're just using the we we use
gaslighting as a joke obviously but like
now we're using their terms he doesn't
even use it properly position the
position isn't that okay I'm trying to
make the argument that to justify put
ejacuate a hole was for was straw man
and what I'm talking man not the
gaslighting you [__] I what the only
argument is that I'm making in this
regards because again shooting someone
over a sticker that would be silly
though it wasn't simply that I think
it's being kind of disingenuous to even
just kind of classified as all this guy
just merely oh just being funny just put
a little put a couple of Sni stickers up
that was uh but that's what he do is
there more am I missing something else
to they did you know they just th threw
on there and like that there was no
nothing being said or no drawings or any
of that that had anything chion I don't
know what the was there a threat of
violence well yeah of course there's
been actionable threats
and but even then now he won't say it
this was one of my favorite parts of
this right because we know we know what
the threat was I'm GNA hold you down and
I'm going to shave your arms the whole
he doesn't want to say it and Nick knows
what it is this is one of the best parts
of this because Nick Nick does the Nick
is one of the I gotta say one of the
best in the business when it comes to
feigning not knowing something when it
comes to pretending to be stupid and
pretending not to know what's going on
look at his Blank Stare when he goes oh
wow I had no idea what what were some of
the threats specifically the guy was
there was because because of that he's
recorded himself on video saying that
well this is supposedly an actionable
threat whether you now the old argument
is that Riley's [__] his legal
opion that part and Riley will probably
agree with you to be fair Riley will
probably agree with you I was howling
when I watched this live because I think
like 5 minutes prior I had just said
Riley's [__] I'm like Riley's a
[__] he's not going to hurt anybody
and then two minutes later Nick's like
yeah but Riley's a [__] I'm like no no
I'm
saying all right so my well my position
is is someone first of all is stalking
for someone to drive across the country
that's not stock look at my favorite
thing about watching is Ric's face like
when he says stalking look what he look
some once drive across the country while
I was watching this I just took a bunch
of screenshots every time [__] Nick
made a face I liked at a business that
again isn't public and when I say it's
not public Rada I'm not saying that uh
someone can't access it that's not the
argument it is that I'm make it that's
exactly what it means if it's p it's not
public there's a car wrap place next
door there's a custom auto place next
door saying that this is not something
that there's no Commerce happening there
right in that specific building so that
we are at but there's Commerce happening
in the in the suite next to yours
correct the unit next to yours because
again I want to reiterate sir what you
have is basically an apartment for
businesses that is what a commercial
park is it's a business apartment
complex hey I can't afford my own entire
[__] brick and mortar warehouse but
you know what there's sweet 385 in the
[__] industrial park and it's Dirt
Cheap because it's right next to the
airport and the air quality is terrible
you know what I mean and the water
quality is
terrible way that you can get in there
are two ways that you can get in there's
a gate there's a private gate that you
can get in uh that way or you can drive
there is a ro kind of Drive in but that
does not face it's not a you can drive
into a driveway into the parking lot
right yeah you can drive into a driveway
into the parking lot and that's why
strategic huh is there a gate on that
driveway into the parking lot no no no
there's not a into that parking lot no
there's no there's no gate the gate
right because there's a car wrap place
and they need to be able to wrap
cuz you can't block off again other
people's business Apartments it's a
public road it's a public road around on
the again it's like I was saying if I
when I lived in my old apartments right
there was two two units upstairs two
units downstairs and it would be like if
I added a chain to like this to get to
the second story and I'd be like nope
nobody comes in or out the Second Story
unless I say so hey [__] there's
people that live next door that pay the
same amount you do which is the only
other way to access it however where
we're you cannot draw there's no place
to go going that direction towards our
building that will then like you can't
there's no reason to be over there it
doesn't matter it's this is the part
where I was SC it's a public road there
doesn't need to be a reason to be back
there what if you get lost and end up
there what if you just [__] feel like
taking a detour and be like hey let me
see what businesses are back here or as
Nick points out at one point what yeah
like what if you're lost or what if
you're just taking a phone call and you
just pull over for a second what a
[__] [__] also I want to point out
that Mr libertarian here wants to use
the state to crush Riley uh so Riley
will stop being mean to him on the
internet meanwhile the black guy who's
the libertarian is now using the the
really shitty flimsy cop Arguments for
not getting you like when they go let me
get your ID and you're like have have I
been accused of anything and they're
like well you just you know you're
hanging around you you got no reason to
be around you like when cop cops do that
Eric you sound like a cop right now oh
you know you can let me search I'll get
the dog I'm just saying you're sitting
here in your car you're just hanging
around you know it's night time in this
Industrial Park you have no business to
be here you're not telling me why you're
here I want your ID and you're like have
I been accused of a crime you know it's
almost like he doesn't have any actual
convictions or principles
nope and let's say again you're coming
to see us you're invited or something of
that nature there's something of that
nature that's again ejaculating no
drive-thru like our building is section
that way the way that it is it's us and
that's it such the way in the way that
it is by the way in the chat Somebody
went this black guy has neck on the
ropes yeah is there and that's it you
cannot drive through our building to get
or our side of that building to get
somewhere else that's not so what that's
a moot point that point is moot yeah
that's also how a lot of these
Industrial and Commercial parks are
right they'll have multiple entrances
available but in order to deter crime
and in order to have sort of control and
over the flow of things if it's not a
super busy area they'll close off some
exits so that way people can't Rob your
[__] and take off out of side exit that
way you can have cameras at the front
exit and they'll just have that for like
that's very common sir just because your
your [__] side entrance isn't open TR
Gun Club goes are you saying there are
walls to this building some sort of
parking
area
this this blocking off that side of the
building yes correct on that side there
absolutely is a gate blocking both sides
theit actually because on the end of
that street or not a street I guess that
road whatever you want to call it it is
a street or road but I digress Public
Road the drive the parking lot right if
you will there are two gates on on
either side this is why he drove through
had to turn around to get out because
that's the only way that you can get in
or out on that on that particular side
so again that clar clarify sorry can you
you said
it there was a gate on one side but the
other side didn't have a gate and there
was a driveway from there's layers of
why this is funny right cuz Nick's not
an idiot Eric is really dumb but also
that I remember this stream Nick was
already a little bit into the sauce that
night yeah so that's kind of making
things even better cuz he's kind of like
being a little drunk and dealing with
somebody who's infinitely more [__]
than you even though you're drunk is
making the braing go wait what uh am I
dumb like he's taking that moment to go
maybe I'm stupid cuz I've been drinking
tonight no no no all Eric's the dumb one
he had to do was say okay you don't like
my comic that's it that's all that had
to happen the road into it correct that
side is still the same but what I'm the
I mean you have to see it now he wants
to shoot people over stickers is that
I'm saying you have a picture the other
I'm certainly not showing it online uh I
do have for sure which means that it's
nothing can you privately send it to me
I won't I won't pull it up can you can
you message it to
me hum hum hum I guess yeah but I'm
explain how it is that it is yes Nick
you can get to it from the road and
there's no gate there what I'm saying is
okay well then [__] it's publicly
accessible which means that he can be
there and you're dumb buffoonery
buffoonery other way having a bunch of
money does not make you
smart you got to understand that to get
in is a gate on the opposite side so for
example our building is at the end of
this lot if you want to if you want to
uh call it that you can get out during
that lot but there are two gates on both
Sid it doesn't matter there's a public
road there's a public
road right that's the only way you can
get in and the only way you can get out
without driving through the side that
the idiot came from right but that's
that's what I'm saying I know but this
this so confusing the only way hey guys
you guys just aren't getting it the only
way into this place other than the two
gated access is the public access yeah
that's basically it you're saying
there's Gates on either side but then
you're saying that he drove through
another side and got so look at it like
three sides because there's nothing but
fening this is like every deposition
I've ever seen when a guy represents
himself and he's going up against a
lawyer yeah and you're I mean why didn't
you bring get a lawyer or this like an
episode of the first 48 where he's just
just completely just no but like you
know there was lighting but like not
good lighting yeah was not lit but it
was very lit up on on on one side right
so you have a fence look at it like this
like you got a fence right and then on
opposite sides of that of that fence
right is is our say fence more is our
building right you can get out so get on
the street do whatever you need to do
there are two sides if you went left or
if you went right there are Gates on
both sides there is only one way if
you're not entering through that gate to
get in to where our building is not
everybody else's building to get in to
where our building was he like a former
gang banger or some [__] like that I
doubt it I think that's made up I doubt
it talking about raada
oh oh well that's totally
believable no but yeah no I know cuz he
was like rap rock metal guy and like it
was like yeah I don't I don't know man
he's like the what is it the yeah the
rap metal and then like the comic book
he's into too many white white boy
things to be to
be he's like Tech 9 okay building is
there's only one way to get in not using
those two gates so there's Forest momy
said he grew up middle class but had
divorced parents a way to get in without
using the gate correct okay but yeah
like hey can we borrow your Rumble
plaque we'll give it back I see it be
borrow it can we borrow it like you see
the issue there right that there is a
publicly accessible way in without a
gate issue was far
what I
mean look at look look at Nick I I know
this is another part you can tell he's
doing
the what don't you
understand he's trying not to laugh um
okay so you can have if you have three
entrances and two gates and one of them
is just an ungated entrance to a public
road that's not fenced in it's not
gated ah
man not from that side it's not
no you're
buffone one of the dumbest human beings
on the face of the planet bro yeah know
I but I'm saying what do you mean like
what do you mean as far as the issue I'm
like I'm I'm not I'm not understanding
what it is your meaning there well if
you can if you can drive in from a
public road I'm I'm having trouble
seeing it as private is all that's see
all right so now now it's it's more of a
I guess semantics or you want to argue
illegal no it's more
you want to argue illegal yeah it's a
lawyer you're talking to about legality
yeah what we were doing I'm not trying
I'm not making an argument that you
can't get there like any making an
argument you're making an argument for
justifiable homicide that's a legal
argument yeah but it's not a legal
argument it's a feelings argument he
feels like you shouldn't be there okay
there let's say to get to our so this
all could be this all could be [__]
solved very easily call the police and
have them Criminal Ally trespassed yeah
that's it oh yeah well they didn't do
that so but that's all you have to do
and then if he comes back you call the
police and they [__] arrest him
argument I'm making he feels that Riley
trespassed even though Riley was not
asked to leave by anybody he did not
speak to anybody on the premises uh no
police report was ever filed he was
never contacted in any way shape or form
by Ripple or any of his all you have to
do is have the cops come and say hey
give me your ID and they take your ID
and write your info down and they hand
you a piece of paper and they go here
you're not allowed back here don't come
back if you come back we arrest you and
then you leave it's that
simple only position it is that I but
also that wouldn't even work either cuz
he technically not trespassing because
there's other suits there and might you
might you might be able to criminally
trespass them from the rip averse but
then the you can still go to the car W
Place well no you could do that but then
then it makes like the pictures and him
looming around still more like you know
what I mean like like if I get
criminally tresp pass from you know
[__] Tires Plus and there's a goddamn
uh Mobile gas station that I usually go
into and they [__] you know
criminally trespass me from the Mobile
gas station if I'm getting my tires
rotated I can't start like if I'm
already criminally if I'm posting
pictures to social media and going oh
I'm right over here Mobile Gas like they
could theoretically get me arrested
because you're still [__] with them
no they can't they would have to have a
protective order but it would be a very
good it would be a very good piece of
evid for a protective order yeah I have
is that our building our our building as
far as accessing it and being in there
like any anywhere near there the only
Reon I already watched the stream I
would have heard it already they invited
they were invited there drove into the
just drove into the driveway drove drove
into when I'm talking about you don't
need an invitation to drive into the
driveway right like no you don't need an
invitation to drive into the driveway
what I'm saying is there's no reason for
someone to be there I think that's not
how any of this SW oh my God you imagine
if could you imagine back in the day if
you got kicked out of the mall for not
having a reason to be there how many
times have you gone to the mall just to
like look around see if they got
anything you want like I've gotone to
mall meet my drug dealer meet your drug
dealer you know maybe see what movies
are out and realize you don't want to
see any of them you know that whole
[__] deal be like fine I'll guess to
go to pan Express but bro imagine them
just walking around kicking everyone out
of the mall go what are you doing here
you you're shopping B you're not
shopping you get out you have no
business to be at the mall bro people
people that used to like him have really
turned on Eric jly now anho people
people are just [__] cannot cannot
stand them we're coming up towards the
end here uh Chuck north gun club yo uh
I'm going shoot you for trespassing to
my warehouse but you're the aggressor
Jack cat your isome comic is probably by
the puppet please grab the puppet for
Mur no I know where that is either no
your your isome is downstairs I don't
think you brought it up here fair enough
fair enough uh cuz I've been enjoying it
so much downstairs in my reading my my
uh in my library it looks like a book
that LeBron James owns yeah I'm sorry
sir and just like the LeBron James book
I've only read the first three pages
that's what I mean there's not even a
crack there's not even a crease on the
cover we want to keep it Mint Condition
uh-huh also I'm sorry if you're not
reading your Ison book in your library
you're doing it wrong it's not in my
library library yeah you're right true
wolf if Eric is just uh black larna give
it a few years you'll start dating a
[__] to real that reel that black guy
with the glasses energy yeah well look
he my I didn't realize what a aoon he
was till he started trying to understand
trying to expl speaking why he could
shoot somebody in Texas because of
stickers yeah well you guys have just
never read rothbard no I haven't or you
know what else I've never read Isam so
I'm happy doing both of those
things